le patrimoine national vient de
s'enrichir de manuscrits de lettres de
jean paul sartre et de simone de
beauvoir les deux écrivains dont le
souvenir hante à jamais le quartier
latin et saint germain des prés en
particulier se sont beaucoup écrit
rappelez-vous les célèbres lettres aux
castors que sartre et écrivait à simone
de beauvoir
toute une époque revécu ici en quelques
photos c'était l'après guerre saint
germain des prés le jazz et boris vian
et surtout la nouvelle pensée
philosophique elle était plus souvent
signées sartre beauvoir grâce à la
dation de l'héritière de simone de
beauvoir la bibliothèque nationale a
récupéré un beau trésor les lignes
noires pour écrire au charmant castor
ali à simone de beauvoir des lignes
bleues pour réconforter le solde à
sartre alias jean-paul perdu sur le
front de la drôle de guerre en 1939
quand ils n'étaient pas ensemble ils
s'écrivaient entre 38 et 63 en tout cas
après cette date le couple mythique
s'est mise au téléphone dans ces six
cent cinquante lettres aucun
laisser-aller jamais une phrase simple
jusque dans la vie privée les deux
écrivains continuer à débattre de leurs
idées de leurs romans le signe d'un
manque de sincérité pouvoir qu'il avait
eu l'impression que c'est la traiter un
peu un témoignage sur sa vie c'est qu'un
jour peut-être on pourrait les publier
mais au moment même où les écrits je ne
pense pas qu'ils les écrits parce qu'il
est la représentation elle en tout cas
pas du tout à la correspondance ajoute
trois romans et des journaux intimes du
castor et les deux dernières oeuvres
philosophiques de sartre la critique de
la raison dialectique et son énorme
flaubert la bn possède désormais un
sartre quasi complets la vedette du
couple
c'était lui mais c'est d'elle que
viennent les documents les plus neufs
ces lettres et est inédite elles ne
seront publiés que l'année prochaine
épistolier certain qu'elle reconnaissait
en sabre et elle révèle aussi une
personnalité pleine d'humour et assez à
ses attachantes les lettres les mots
jetés sur les pages le seul et dernier
moyen de rester à séparables sport